اتهمنا المندوب الروسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي
بسيليا الدول الغربيه بالتواطئ في ارتكابي
ما وصفه بجرائم حرب وذلك بسبب استمرارها
بمد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الثقيله اكد خلال
جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس الامن الدولي دعت لها
موسكو لبحث امدادات الاسلحه الغربيه الى
اوكرانيا اكد ان الغرب يريد تحقيق هزيمه
استراتيجيه لروسيا
بسهوله
من انظمه الاسلحه القويه ونقلها المستمر
الى كيف لتنفيذ الضربات وتدريب القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه على اراضها يعني ان
الدول التي تفعل ذلك ليست فقط اطرافا في
النزاع المسلح مع روسيا وذلك وفقا
لاتفاقيه لاهايل لعام
1907 بشان حقوق الدول المحايده في الحرب
والتزاماتها لكنها متواطئه ايضا في جرائم
الحرب التي ترتكبها القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه والكتائب القوميه
وفي المقابل قال روبرت وود نائب المندوبه
الامريكيه في مجلس الامن الدوليه ان
الاسلحه التي تقدمها واشنطن واصدقاء
اوكرانيا الاخرون ليست سببا في استمرار
حرب روسيا غير المبرره على اوكرانيا
دعمت الولايات المتحده بقوه حقه اوكرانيا
في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد حرب روسيا
العدوانيه الوحشيه غير المبرره سنواصل
القيام بذلك مع خمسين دوله اخرى ان توفير
الاسلحه للدفاع عن اراضي اوكرانيا لا يؤدي
الى تمديد هذا الصراع او مفاقمته ساعدت
شحنات الاسلحه هذه على منع روسيا من
ممارسه مزيد من الوحشيه على المدنيين
الاوكرانيين واجبارهم على ترك منازلهم
وزياده تكاليف الطاقه والغذاء في جميع
انحاء اوروبا وحول العالم